hello dr. Peterson hey there we go
tonight I'd like to ask you about two
different psychological disorders
the first being borderline personality
disorder so two lectures ago somebody
asked you about it and you gave a very
sparse answer I can't remember exactly
what you said but it seemed like it was
a it way there was too much complexity
to just answer it right there and then
and then somebody else also Acts asked
you about the same disorder in your
patreon livestream recently and when
they when they asked you that you kind
of you kind of solved for a moment and
something I don't know something kind of
flicked on in your head it seemed like
and you and you thought for a couple
seconds and then you said you know what
I don't think that I can answer that
right now because just to it's just too
bloody complex and I was wondering just
like many young men have gravitated
towards your lectures do you think that
there's something about this particular
disorder that there's something about
people with this particular disorder
that might gravitate to your insights
and your lectures okay okay so no I
would say probably no to the second one
but I could comment more about
borderline personality disorder I think
I have enough mental energy to do that
tonight so technically speaking it's
often considered the female variant of
antisocial personality disorder so it's
it's it's it's classified or it's
classified in in in the domain of
externalizing disorders acting out
disorders and I think what happens we
don't understand borderline personality
disorder very well and it's
characterized by tremendous impulsivity
radical confusion of identity and then
this pattern of idealization of people
with whom the person afflicted with the
disorder is associating with radical
idealization of those people and then
radical devaluation of them and then
there's another theme that sort of
weaves along with it which is
the proclivity of people with borderline
personality disorder to presume that
they will be abandoned and then to act
in a manner that makes such abandonment
virtually certain and so it's a very
complicated disorder but that I think
gets at the crux of it one of the things
that's interesting about people with
borderline personality disorder in my
experience is that they're often quite
intelligent and you you see in the
person with borderline personality
disorder something like the waist or the
squandering of tremendous potential they
seem capable of thinking through the
nature of their problems and analyzing
it and discussing it but not capable
whatsoever of implementing any solutions
and technically there's no relationship
between I I Q and conscientiousness it's
very weird because if you read the
neuropsychological literature and you
read about the functions of the
prefrontal cortex they're usually
conceptualized in intellectual terms and
they're associated with planning and
strategizing and so forth and that's
what conscientiousness is is planning
and strategizing in implementation but
the correlation between IQ and
conscientiousness is zero and so as the
correlation between working memory and
conscientiousness zero and zero is a
very low correlation right I mean really
it's hard to find things in psychology
that are correlated at zero things tend
to be correlated to some degree they
tend to be interrelated the borderline
seems to be able to strategize and to
abstract but not to be able to implement
and and so this the intellect per se
seems to be functional but it's not
embodied in action it's very so it can
be frustrating to be associated with
someone who has borderline personality
disorder because
they can tell you what the problem is
and even tell you what the solution
might be but there's no implementation
so maybe something went wrong
developmentally we don't know exactly
how these sorts of things come about the
other thing that seems to be
characteristic of borderline people with
borderline personality disorder is that
they they remind me very much of people
who are 2 years old and in some manner
like people with borderline personality
disorder can have temper tantrums in
fact they often do and you know now and
then you see a temper tantrum and
they're usually thrown by two-year-olds
right
most people go out of temper tantrums by
the time they're about three they're
very rare at for it which is a good
thing because if they're still there at
four that is not a good diagnostic
predictor that's a match like a good
diagnostic predictor but it's not the
kind that you want and you know it's
funny the way that we respond to
two-year-old temper tantrums because the
two-year-old will throw themselves on
the ground and eat their hands and their
legs on the floor and scream and yell
and turn red or even blue I saw a child
once who was capable of holding his
breath during a temper tantrum till he
turned blue which was really an
impressive feat you should try that
right it's really hard did you really
have to work at it and you see that in
adult borderlines they'll have temper
tantrums and the funny thing is when a
two-year-old does it it's like it's you
know it's little off-putting but when an
adult does it it's completely bloody
terrifying and it happens very
frequently with borderlines and so I
would also say to some degree they
didn't get properly socialized between
that critical period of development
between two and four and you see the
same thing with adult males who grow up
to the anti-social because a large
proportion of adult males who grow up to
be antisocial are aggressive as children
as two-year-olds so there's a small
proportion of two-year-olds who are
quite aggressive they'll kick and hit
and bite and steal if you put them with
other two-year-olds it's about five
percent of the of the male's smaller
fraction of the females but most of them
are socialized by the time they're four
but there's a small percentage who
aren't and they tend to stay antisocial
and they tend to turn into long term
offenders and then attend the devel the
critical period for socialization
development seems to be between two and
four
it seems to be mediated by pretend play
and rough-and-tumble play and those
sorts of mechanisms and if it isn't
instantiated by the age of four it
doesn't have it and it doesn't look like
it's addressable now there are dialectic
behavioral therapies that have been
developed for people with borderline
personality disorder and they're
purported to be successful